remember titan forum first person
shooter parkour mex pretty much three of
my favorite things so good news for me
because it's getting a sequel but
developer respawn entertainment are also
working on something extra I'm Lucy and
welcome to this drift compatible
gamespot news update a job listing
posted on Gamasutra has revealed that
the studio is looking for designers with
to game development projects a new game
in the titanfall universe as well as a
new third-person action-adventure IP it
continues respawn is seeking a senior
level designer to embrace and contribute
to the project vision breathing life
into the game play world and helping
define the moment-to-moment player
experience news at the studio was
developing a second game alongside
titanfall to first broke in December
2014 when studio co-founder Vince
Zampella said there is a second team
respawn non titanfall related dig as
missing a veteran industry designer who
served as creative director for god of
war 3 joined respawn in jun 2014 adding
some 3rd person action game expertise to
the studio respawn officially confirmed
titanfall 2 in march 2015 but hasn't
provided details on what the follow-up
will end tale but zampella has said I
promised that it will be worth the wait
but what about if your ps4 player
remember that titanfall wasn't xbox and
pc exclusive well Zampella has revealed
that the sequel may see a multi-platform
release but not for a while EA has
confirmed that titanfall 2 will arrive
at the earliest later this year so are
you excited for titanfall 2 any idea
what this other project could be who are
you drift compatible with let me know in
the comment section below or come find
me on Twitter at Lucy James games for
all the latest mekinese keep it gamespot
you